>> Tucker:
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," IN CASE
YOU DON’T READ IT, IT’S STILL
BEING PUBLISHED WHERE THEY WERE
IN A PIECE WITH HIS HEADLINE,
"ALARM, DENIAL, BLAME, THE TRUMP
MEDIA DISTORTION."
IN THE TELLING OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
CORONAVIRUS ON THIS COVERAGE
FOLLOWED A CERTAIN PATTERN.
THE PATTERN THEY TOLD US WHEN
THIS WAY.
BLAME CHINA.
ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," "WHEN THE
VIRUS RAVAGED CHINA, SOME
PUNDITS ON THE RIGHT ONE THE
COUNTRY COULD BE TRUSTED TO
CONTAIN THE OUTBREAK OR SHARE
ACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE
IT ORIGINATED."
[LAUGHS]
CAN YOU BELIEVE THEY THOUGHT
THAT?
WHERE THEY GET THAT IDEA?
BECAUSE IT IS TRUE.
THE NEAR TIMES TIMES DOES THEM
AT THAT.
STEP TWO, PLAYED ON THE RISKS
FOLLOWED BY STEP THREE, SHARE
SURVIVOR STORIES TO SHOW THE
VIRUS WASN’T SO BAD.
STEP FOUR, BLAME THE LEFT.
AS YOU ARE AWARE FROM WATCHING
THIS PROGRAM AND FROM LIVING IN
THIS COUNTRY, WHATEVER THESE
PEOPLE ACCUSE YOU OF DOING IS
100% OF THE TIME EXACTLY WHAT
THEY’RE DOING THEMSELVES.
THAT OF COURSE WAS THE CASE
HERE.
AS YOU KNOW THE ESTABLISHMENT
PRESS HAS BEEN SCREWING UP
CORONAVIRUS STORIES FROM DAY
ONE.
THERE ARE FOUR STEPS TO
UNDERSTANDING THEIR COVERAGE AND
HERE’S WHAT THEY ARE FOR THE
FIRST STEP AS USUAL, BLAME
RACISM.
YOUR TWO "NEW YORK TIMES"
HEADLINES IN THE EARLY DAY OF
THE OUTBREAK, "AN OUTBREAK OF
RACIST SENTIMENT AS CORONAVIRUS
WHICH IS OFTEN A LOOP."
PEOPLE’S BAD OPINIONS ARE WORSE
THAN A PANDEMIC!
HERE IS ANOTHER, "FEAR SPREADS
FASTER THAN THE CORONAVIRUS
CELLS."
OKAY.
AS THE VIRUS KEPT SPREADING
THERE WAS STEP TWO, PLAYED ON
THE RISK.
AS NEAR TO HAMPSTEAD.
ON JANUARY 29 FEET PAPER WARNS
YOU TO BE AWARE OF THE PANDEMIC
PANIC, CALM DOWN!
A WEEK LATER THEY ASKED, WHO
SAYS IT’S NOT SAFE TO TRAVEL TO
CHINA?
BOOK A TICKET TO WUHAN, RACIST?
SOMEHOW TELLING THE PUBLIC THAT
CORONAVIRUS WAS NO BIG DEAL
DIDN’T CONTAIN THE VIRUS, SO
THEY TIMES WANT TO STEP THREE
COME UP WITH POLITICIZE THE
CRISIS.
CALL ME CORONAVIRUS THE CHINESE
VIRUS OF THE WUHAN VIRUS HAS
BIGOTRY, BUT THEY HAD NO PROBLEM
PUBLISHING AN OP-ED SAYING,
"LET’S CALL IT TRUMP VIRUS."
LAST WEEK IN A SHAMEFUL MOMENT
THAT WILL LIVE FOREVER IN THE
END FOR ME.
THE PAPER DECLARED, "THE ROAD TO
CORONAVIRUS HELL WAS PAVED BY
EVANGELICALS."
IT’S REALLY THE FAULT OF
CHRISTIANS, THAT TELLS YOU A LOT
LOT.
THIS WEEK THE PAPER SETTLED ON
ITS FAVORITE STEP.
STEP FOUR, BLAME FOX NEWS.
OF COURSE, AS IF THERE IS A
POLITICAL STRATEGY HERE.
LAST WEEK THEY WARNED ABOUT
"FOX’S FAKE NEWS CONTAGION."
THERE WAS YESTERDAY’S ARTICLE.
TALK ABOUT A LIE.
THEY SHOW IT WAS TELLING YOU
ABOUT THE DISEASE AND JANUARY,
WHEN THEY TIMES WAS WONDERING IF
IT WAS RACIST.
THEY WERE ENCOURAGING YOU TO
TRAVEL TO WUHAN FOR VACATION!
NOW WE ARE HIGHLIGHTING THE
CONTINUED DISHONESTY AND
MALEVOLENCE OF CHINA.
MEANWHILE "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
AND THE STAR REPORTER IS GOING
OVER TO MSNBC TO DELIVER UNPAID
INFOMERCIALS FOR THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
WATCH THIS.
>> IN CHINA THERE ARE 40,000
DOCTORS, NURSES, RESPIRATORY
TECHNICIANS GOING ALL OVER FROM
CHINA TO WUHAN TO HELP THE
DOCTORS FIGHT THE VIRUS.
THERE IS NO MORE VIRUS AND
WUHAN.
THOSE DOCTORS HAVE ALL GONE
HOME.
THERE’VE BEEN VICTORY PARADES
FOR THEM, GRATITUDE, FLOWERS,
EVERYTHING FOR THEIR HEROES.
THEY NOT ONLY HAVE THE SKILLS, A
LOT OF THEM CAUGHT THE VIRUS AND
ARE NOW IMMUNE.
THEY COULD DO A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WOULD BE DANGEROUS TO
SOMEBODY WHO HASN’T GOT THE
VIRUS.
I DON’T SEE WHY WE COULDN’T HIRE
FOR OUR PANDEMIC A LOT OF THOSE
DOCTORS, NURSES, RESPIRATORY
TECHNICIANS.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE DONALD
McNEIL’S EDITOR AND YOU ARE
WATCHING THIS, ARE YOU CALLING
HIS SUPERVISOR SAYING, BRING HIM
AND!
HE IS GIVING AWAY THE TRUTH!
PARIS AND CHINESE DOCTORS TO RUN
OUR HOSPITALS.
THAT IS HIS TAKE.
THAT IS NOT SURPRISING THOUGH,
APPARENTLY CHINESE DOCTORS
ALREADY RUN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
NEW UNEMPLOYMENT FIGURES ARE
HORRIFYING, THE LARGEST IN